The German companyBioNTechpartnered with
Pfizer to develop and test a coronavirus vaccine
known asBNT162b2. A clinical trial demonstrated
that the vaccine has anefficacy rateof
95 percent in preventing Covid-19.
The SARS-CoV-2 virus is studded with proteins
that it uses to enter human cells. These so-called
spike proteins make a tempting target for
potential vaccines and treatments. Like the
Moderna vaccine, the Pfizer-BioNTech vaccine
is based on the virus’s genetic instructions
for building the spike protein.
The vaccine uses messenger RNA, genetic material
that our cells read to make proteins. The
molecule — called mRNA for short — is
fragile and would be chopped to pieces by
our natural enzymes if it were injected directly
into the body. To protect their vaccine, Pfizer
and BioNTech wrap mRNA in oily bubbles made
of lipid nanoparticles. Because of their fragility,
the mRNA molecules will quickly fall apart
at room temperature. Pfizer is building special
containers with dry ice, thermal sensors and
GPS trackers to ensure the vaccines can be
transported at -94 degrees Fahrenheit to stay
viable.
After injection, the vaccine particles bump
into cells and fuse to them, releasing mRNA.
The cell’s molecules read its sequence and
build spike proteins. The mRNA from the vaccine
is eventually destroyed by the cell, leaving
no permanent trace. Some of the spike proteins
form spikes that migrate to the surface of
the cell and stick out their tips. The vaccinated
cells also break up some of the proteins into
fragments, which they present on their surface.
These protruding spikes and spike protein
fragments can then be recognized by the immune
system.
When a vaccinated cell dies, the debris will
contain many spike proteins and protein fragments,
which can then be taken up by a type of immune
cell called an antigen-presenting cell. The
cell presents fragments of the spike protein
on its surface. When other cells called helper
T-cells detect these fragments, the helper
T-cells can raise the alarm and help marshal
other immune cells to fight the infection.
Other immune cells, called B-cells, may bump
into the coronavirus spikes and protein fragments
on the surface of vaccinated cells. A few
of the B-cells may be able to lock onto the
spike proteins. If these B-cells are then
activated by helper T-cells, they will start
to proliferate and pour out antibodies that
target the spike protein.
The antibodies can latch onto coronavirus
spikes, mark the virus for destruction and
prevent infection by blocking the spikes from
attaching to other cells.
The antigen-presenting cells can also activate
another type of immune cell called a killer
T-cell to seek out and destroy any coronavirus-infected
cells that display the spike protein fragments
on their surfaces.
The Pfizer-BioNTech vaccine requires two injections,
given 21 days apart, to prime the immune system
well enough to fight off the coronavirus.
But because the vaccine is so new, researchers
don’t know how long its protection might
last. It’s possible that in the months after
vaccination, the number of antibodies and
killer T-cells will drop. But the immune system
also contains special cells called memory
B-cells and memory T-cells that might retain
information about the coronavirus for years
or even decades.